in your mind
are you the starter here for that game
against the cardinals after what you did
today
i think going into next week um i just
want to continue to
impact the guys around me um just work
hard every day
is jalen your starter next week and if
so
what will the challenge be you know now
that more tape is out on him
you know i'm gonna um i'm gonna enjoy
this one i'm gonna go home and
relax and be with my family tonight and
enjoy this win and get ready for the
week
you know what made the top button swag
even more impressive for jalen hurts can
we pull
up an image of that the top button was a
different color than the other buttons
yeah that's a new little
twist that's a new little i like that
yeah i like that all right i'll try to
infuse that so you can give you should
do that
stitch in stitch in some different
colored buttons at the very top
yup hey his guy's got style he's got
charisma i mean
he's the man listen there's so much to
respect about jalen hurts the way he
acts and carries himself i mean i really
do love that
i do and you know i mean first off like
with doug peterson there i know he's
probably happy as hell i won a football
game
i mean but i mean come on philadelphia
media
of course he's going to start next week
what of course
well i mean everything that the eagles
made the move for with jalen hurts give
the team a lift
you know give us a jump start some
energy all that showed right from the
start of the football game yesterday i
mean we were all sitting there watching
it
it was a parent you know i don't know
what that is
you know again i don't know if it's
carson wentz or whatever but everybody
picked up their play
you know and i think listen mike this is
i don't even know where we're supposed
to start of this
to me the shocking moment of the whole
game
and everything about it jalen hurts i
know we're gonna talk about that
but to me was more of the lack of no
game plan by the saints for jalen hurts
it's like
they didn't think he was gonna run he
dropped back to pass they just rushed
him like crazy men
there was no spies to stop him they
never
made jalen hurts have to really be a
drop back quarterback they let him go
hey here's a one-on-one ball throw it up
right i talk about this all the time
this is these are things young
quarterbacks want oh wait
no decision of being blitzed let me
throw one on one i don't have to read a
defense great
oh wait they've they've parted the red
sea and there's nobody
spying me and i'm a running quarterback
anyways now i can run
i mean that's what won the game his
design quarterback runs and his ability
to scramble in some certain situations
his speed is real i mean it's real it
can
change the field it's that type of speed
and that to me was more shocking than
anything because the saints as we know
have been so awesome lately
especially on the defensive side of the
ball and we had sean payton the saints
coach on pft pm last tuesday and
we were talking about this whole cat and
mouse game of keeping it close to the
vest
who your quarterback is going to be and
he kind of shrugged at the idea that
there was
any real benefit to knowing or not
knowing who the eagles quarterback would
be because he saw
great similarities between wentz and
hertz
but they may have similar styles
generally yeah but as you said there's
something more to hertz
that he brings to the table and now
maybe we're seeing why they made him a
second round draft pick
what they saw in him it's just one game
but when it's the team that holds the
number one seed in your conference
and you play that well against him
number one of course you're gonna be the
starter next week and
i i i don't i don't want to pick on
questions made during press conferences
because i've asked plenty of stupid
questions in my day and i won't ask
plenty more
trust me but the idea that you would
consider going back to carson wentz
because there's film now on jalen hurts
are you kidding me
but you're going to go with the guy
who's playing well right period
and you deal with the fact that there's
film out there and you you counter punch
you add whatever you think you're going
to do to take them away yeah you put
more on his plate now that you see that
he can handle what you gave him for the
first
week it worked it was a resounding
success the best game of the year came
in the first game that carson wentz
didn't start yes
so we finally have some glimmer of hope
in philadelphia
of course he's going to start
this weekend this gets ridden
this horse rides until it dies or it
kicks you off of it
period yeah that's right and you know
they found something i think they found
a style of play
that you know suits their football team
we've had this talk before
and really as i was sitting there
watching it with coach dungey and rodney
yesterday
you know coach dungy brought it up where
it's like hey
philadelphia has like a plan of attack
today and they're going to run the
football and play
tough defense and do that instead of
just like hey carson get in the shotgun
and you know we'll just call every pass
play we have and you change him at the
line of scrimmage and do all of that
and you know maybe that's a big part of
the problem there
the fact that there's no identity there
and they just give carson wentz too much
leeway to do whatever he wants
and they don't form a formula or an
identity for their offense that works
you know it's it's the second time in
the doug peterson era we've seen this a
little bit where nick foles comes in and
things get more concise
jalen hurts comes in it gets more
concise but
either way it's not a good look for
carson wentz that the team and the
energy and everything looked that way
yesterday and of course they win that
football game
i mean it's getting to the point mike i
mean i don't know i mean not to the
point but
man i mean another game like this or
something i don't know what you do in
philadelphia they're going to have to
look to trade to carson wins maybe
carson once should want to get the hell
out of there anyways now
i don't know where it goes but uh good
for jalen hurts and a big time win for
the eagles and they really shook up the
nfc
well on carson west the eagles are
already starting to lay the foundation
to trade him by putting out the word in
the sunday splash
reports that that they plan to keep him
that's step one
if you're gonna get trade value for the
guy you have to start telling all the
reporters
that you plan to keep him so you have
some some leverage when it's time to
have the trade talks
but another point the saints had not
given up a 100 yard rusher in 55 games
they gave up
two yesterday miles sanders had 115
jalen hurts had 106.
246 rushing yards allowed by the saints
defense and the saints offense wasn't
horrible and the game
ultimately got closer i got to give the
saints credit for hanging in there and
not folding the tents when they were
down big
but the defense just let them down this
defense that we had been praising every
week let them down
on sunday chris yeah i was shocked by it
really am
and like i said to start the the segment
here with this conversation just
more or less shocked about
the lack of the game plan for jalen
hurts and mike
you know i didn't realize sean payton
had said that to you last week but
it showed they played defense like they
thought it was carson wentz and that's
that and you know
no he's not carson wentz he has another
gear when he tucks the football
that carson wentz does not have i mean
we you saw it yesterday when jalen hurts
turn the corner
the speed is real he certainly can
outrun linebackers
and he's going to make some dbs look
slow and things like that too so it's
dangerous that way
and you know now that he's got a feel
for the game
and the speed and getting in and out of
the huddle and doing all those things
now like you said they can add a few
more things to his plate
maybe a few more game plan design runs
maybe a few passes that
hey we didn't want to put in this week
because he wasn't reading it quite
perfectly yet but this
you know another week of practice now we
can throw it in you know so we'll see
where it goes but either way it was a
good start for him and the eagles
taysom hill wasn't horrible in start
number four he just wasn't
spectacular and yeah they need drew
brees back and jay glazer i think
suggested during the
fox pregame show yesterday that they're
targeting the christmas
day game against the vikings for drew
brees return so it maybe takes him to
no chiefs weekend against no chiefs yeah
yeah but but look if if the defense
isn't going to show up
it does not matter if the defense isn't
going to have a better plan
to stop patrick mahomes than whatever
plan they had to stop jalen hurts
it's not going to matter and the number
one seed as a result
thrown back toward the green bay packers
who
hold the head-to-head tiebreaker over
the saints by virtue of a week three
victory on sunday night football
that was a long long time ago but the
packers won that game
and so at ten and three tied with the
saints at 10 and three
the packers are the one seed and there
are the rams lurking look
the the the packers have two games that
they easily
should win all due respect to the bears
and panthers
the titans game is a a little bit of a
question
but you know the the rams don't have an
easy road either with the seahawks in
the cardinals
i think the packers are in great shape
57
chance to capture the 1c that's the
steve kornacki probability from last
night and i think it makes sense and
look at how it flipped from 58
for the saints going into yesterday's
game to 57
for the packers and if the road to tampa
is going through lambeau field chris
your guy aaron rodgers may indeed be
facing patrick mahomes
when early february rolls oh gosh i hope
so i just i think drool just came out of
my mouth when you said that okay that's
how excited i got
all right i mean that would be so
amazing but i to me that is like one of
the biggest
playoff like in a year where there's no
home field advantage fans all that kind
of things
to me that's the one that jumped out we
heard coach dungy talk about it in the
clip
i know i said it last night on the show
that is a
a big thing for me yeah aaron rodgers at
home in lambeau
and especially if you get there late in
january it could be five
10 12 degrees and he can still throw
lasers through that kind of weather
and not all quarterbacks can and drew
brees would certainly be that one where
you'd question
wait we've seen drew brees not look
great in those kind of elements and
things before
uh as compared to you know the dome
where they know they're warm and cozy
and they can throw the ball all over the
place so
uh that that to me is is interesting
certainly but a lot of football left to
be played
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports